perdu je crois que j'aurais dû prendre
une autre rue à temps ou est-ce que tu
habites rue des favorites
c'est super non non mais laisse tomber
un ti sera jamais avant la nuit ouvre la
porte
alors ok mais juste un petit tour toi
qui commande
est on en train de sortir de la villa
non
en fait seulement que tu vois la base de
loisirs tout le monde s'y retrouve le
week-end et nager thème sa j'adore
je suis sûr que miss america c'est une
bombe atomique en maillot de bain
avancer les biens vous faites quoi bon à
rien on est là pour se détendre
il vaut mieux que je rentre je crois
c'est trop pour une première journée est
relax elle s'est encore un peu on fait
connaissance c'est que du bonheur